the nation has a new set of climate
normals every 10 years the national
oceanic and atmospheric administration
releases updated temperature
and rainfall averages based on thousands
of weather stations from across the
country
meteorologist and climate specialist
jeff varadelli is here to explain
why the latest normals are anything but
normal
these new norms jeff thank you for being
here what is so significant
about what has taken place here in these
new numbers so this story has garnered a
lot of attention and the reason why it's
garnered a lot of attention
is because of this bright red map that
we're about to show you right there so
that's a comparison of temperatures from
the early 1900s
to now and basically the whole nation is
warming
and more specifically the parts of the
nation that the climate models
have said would warm are warming exactly
in those patterns so
it is further proof of human-caused
climate change top left
is the early 1900s bottom right is now
and you can
see it speaks for itself doesn't it yeah
where is it warming
the the fastest and the slowest i guess
well
it's warming the fastest exactly where
we don't want it to warm the fastest
towards the west coast of the u.s
and the reason why it's warming faster
there is because it's drier there we
know
in deserts it warms faster right that's
what's happening along the west coast
right now and you can see it's warming
the least in the southeast and the
reason for that
is because it's wetter there it's more
moist there and so you generally
warm a little bit more slowly on the
subject of that rain there are some
distinct patterns when it comes to
rainfall as well right
very distinct and it's exactly what our
computer models have been saying for a
very long time and this is important
because in the west it is drying rapidly
and basically what climate change does
is it intensifies the water cycle so the
wet
get wetter the rich get richer and the
dry get drier so as we compare these
maps in the western united states
it's really drying out we have the worst
drought we've had or second worst
drought in 1200
years and last year we had one of the
worst wire
fire seasons that we have ever seen in
modern history
it's drier this year than it was last
year so we have to prepare for a bad
fire season
in the east it's getting wetter there's
more floods um
extreme rainfall events have gone up 30
to 40 percent that's because the gulf of
mexico is warmer
it's applying more evaporation more
moisture pushing that north into the
mississippi valley
and across the eastern united states so
more floods in the east
hollywood has taken on this issue in
different ways i just want to really
quickly i just want to take this one
clip from
day after tomorrow
okay this is extreme we don't
want this we don't want this but put
this in perspective
um when we see all of these scenes like
this sort of fast-forwarded
in movies so yeah this is outlandish
that is not going to happen
but the movie is based on a real premise
that we're seeing begin to unfold right
now
so let me first show you this map this
is from professor ed hawkins
uh in the uk and what you can see there
dark red
it's warming fast light blue it's
warming slowly
dark blue it's not warming at all look
at that big
blue bullseye near greenland immersed in
a sea of red
that's not good news you want it to cool
right but that is an indication that
something is broken
in the climate system so let's talk
about what is broken right now what's
breaking
it is the gulf stream system which
controls the climate of the earth that
is slowing down there it is right there
it's responsible for redistributing heat
all across the world well so far it's
slowed down around 15
the reason why it's slowing is because
greenland is melting because the arctic
is warming at three times
the pace of the rest of the globe that
water is throwing the whole
current off kilter and what that's going
to do as it continues to slow down could
slow down by 40 to 50 percent by 2100
is it could throw weather patterns
completely off kilter
in the north atlantic and i don't think
jake gyllenhaal and dennis quaid will be
around at that point
to save us but their kids their kids
will be yes their kids will be and their
grandkids yeah that's right but it's not
good but it's not going to be as
dramatic and as outlandish as as the
movies i promise that
all right well done jeff thank you very
much